yo do you have a copy of the John Morant
rookie card that you end offer in the
background of yeah
we got a couple of them a couple fans
gave me that shit's fire yeah if you
just think back like first of all shout
out to John Morant who's
um
one of my he's probably my favorite
player to watch in the league right now
yeah
um but nah that rookie card is wild
yeah super crazy uh I saw uh well you're
obviously a huge Grizzlies fan you guys
are very good right now how does that
feel because the Grizzlies for a little
bit there was rough
after like Marc Gasol and every and Mike
Conley Jr left there was a few rough
years which is how y'all got John Moran
he was the number two overall pick
we wanted the bottom though no I mean
but I mean but you're right you know
okay yeah yeah but now now [ __ ] is lit
no it's up it's up for sure are you
friends with any of the guys
yeah I [ __ ] with the whole team yeah I'm
[ __ ] the whole team even if they
don't know I [ __ ] with them like if you
hung out with John Moran I don't hang
with no basketball players
um
I don't do that why not because my
lifestyle
lifestyle dead too but I don't I don't
want to be the reason for it either so
hey that's real I'd rather I come hoop
with you I don't want you to come to the
studio around me when I'm smoking and
drinking yeah like me
most rappers are the opposite
they just want to hang out with I mean
it's the other way around too though I I
don't like people rappers want to hang
out with basketball players but the
basketball players would be at the
studio with the rappers you see James
Harden with [ __ ] uh you know pretty
much them a r and a damn little baby
album
he's in the studio so much
it's crazy
yeah no that's that's smart though
because I feel like you kind of you know
you gotta ain't gonna say like ain't
nothing wrong with it this just ain't
it's just not me I like hanging with who
I hang with 100 man yeah ain't nothing
against no athletes nundo